- What up, vlog?
It's, you know, just a
normal 2:34 in the morning
here in Atlanta outside the studio.
You know, just a normal day.
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
("Riddles" by Lyam Music)
Thank you.
Excuse factory is open.
I mean, I'm literally
showing people how to make
three, four, five six,
seven, eight, 900 bucks
extra a month minimum
and they're like well,
it's not worth my time.
These are the same people
fucking playing Fortnite
for four hours or Madden
or just like moping around
on the front porch like it's laughable.
So I just looked him up, he's in Buffalo.
So I'm literally on
Craigslist Buffalo right now.
I'm putting in the work.
And I'm gonna show here's free firewood.
Dude, look at this.
- [Camera Man] How much is it?
Is it free?
- Dude, you live in Buffalo.
I looked it up.
I just went to Buffalo Craigslist free.
The third thing I saw was this.
You go pick that up and relist
it on Facebook Marketplace
and you'll make 100 bucks.
Do that ten times and you've made a G.
Better than Netflix.
- [Camera Man] Should I educate you?
- Teach him how to fish.
Teach him how to fucking fish.
I can teach people how to fish two ways.
The best way to teach people how to fish
is watch what I'm fucking doing.
Watch it; all of it.
Why am I podcasting?
What am I putting in my Instagram stories?
Why am I on LinkedIn?
Why do I have an email?
Set up for my email.
Why am I doing these things?
Watch, watch, watch, watch, watch.
Why do I write a lot of copy?
Why am I in my comments?
Or, I can teach people
how to fish literally.
The 180 strategy.
The 86 page deck, the explosion on Twitter
on how to use Craigslist
and Facebook Marketplace
to make $1000 if you hustle
for every fucking person
that's watching period
which is a lot of money
for 75% of the people that are watching.
I'll teach you how to fish two ways.
You just have to fucking fish.
("Riddles" by Lyam Music)
What up, First in Line?
Back of the seat here Chicago to Alabama.
Heading there right now.
You're going to get this text very shortly
so I'll be in the air.
This is the barter site for the sneakers.
Very excited about these three levels.
The party is going to be insanity.
("Give Thanks" by Bugus)
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ New mics and shit, you know ♪
♪ Took my first private flight
about to make it a habit ♪
♪ Passed my camera to my brother ♪
♪ Told him to take it and tag it ♪
♪ Let's make a moment of it ♪
♪ The people home would love it ♪
♪ And if you wonder what's
next, this an omen of it ♪
♪ When my mother's water
broke I was dripped in gold ♪
♪ Picked and told "stick
to the script and role" ♪
♪ The path that you must
now go is a twisted road ♪
♪ Weapon you will now
hold is a fist to throw ♪
♪ A gifted mind, the holy
filled gift is told ♪
♪ The gift is mine, the
only real gift is time ♪
♪ That making other people
rich shit, never in my plans ♪
♪ Knew my whole life would
be better in my hands ♪
♪ As a boy I knew one day I'd be the man ♪
♪ Doing what I want ♪
♪ No one that can tell what I can ♪
♪ So I dream, I plan, I work ♪
- Gary Ellesbonar, nice to see you.
- Such a pleasure.
- I really appreciate
you being here.
- Thank you again.
- No problem.
- Where we going?
- Those were some player helmets.
- [Gary] What's super
interesting about this is
I've gone to campuses.
Most places have like, you
know, the guys that have
gone to League.
You've got so many that
you've had to rotate.
- [Gary] We don't have a wall big enough.
- Uh huh, uh huh.
This is nice.
- Keeping up with the
Joneses is an understatement.
- I'm aware of what that is.
Jesus.
That's cool.
- Ball only here.
- Okay.
- Downstairs is dining
facilities for every other sport.
- Okay.
- These guys have no clue
how good they get it.
- They've got it good, boy.
- Our practice fields.
We've got three natural grass fields.
The indoors with the windows.
The indoor practice facilities.
The brick building.
- Amazing, man; it's crazy.
What a program, huh?
- He absolutely demands that his players
are surrounded by the very
best people and resources
as possible, so.
He's doing a pretty damn good job of it.
- Sure is.
A lot of winning helps
you get a lot of leverage
to be able to do what you need to do.
- No doubt.
- We're at 'Bama.
This is pretty cool.
- [Gary] Yeah, that's all
the first round draft picks.
First rounder draft
picks, not second, third,
fourth, fifth, sixth; first rounders.
- This one did not work
out for us, unfortunately.
- Getting the line up, you
know, whatever you need.
- This is pretty much the most...
Like this little thing right here could be
the deal sealer for some guys.
This might have made me commit.
No excuses.
That's exactly right.
- I'm JT, by the way.
- Hey, JT, I'm Gary.
Nice to meet you, man.
How you doing?
- I'm doing well.
How 'bout you?
- Good.
- How was your flight?
- Real good.
(laughing)
- [Man] That's what I'm
freaking talking about.
You need him, you get him.
What's up, dog?
- Such a pleasure.
- Man, so good to meet you, brother.
- Thank you so much for having me.
I'm really glad to be here.
- What's up, guys, you all doing good?
Everything good?
I got some time.
Dude.
- Dude, I'm so pumped
to be here.
- You have no idea.
- What a fucking facility.
Jesus Christ.
No wonder you guys win every fucking game.
- Come on, baby.
- Man, there's so much of
even what I saw in the hallway
that I'm like yep.
No excuses is fucking everything.
You eliminate that, everything changes.
You embrace accountability
and it's fucking game over
in life.
I believe in that shit so much.
- [Man] This is T. O., my right hand man.
- How we doing?
- Gary.
How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Real pleasure, how are things?
- Good.
- Marcus.
- What's up, man?
- D-Rock.
- Nice to meet you.
- So now I'm invading
sports, I start this thing.
You know, like, crazy story.
I bought it because I wanted
to learn because I want
to buy the Jets and not even
really thinking about it.
Was really going to be
like this thing I watched
just to learn the game, just to be
player-friendly one day that my brother,
who has Crohn's disease,
decides to bounce of VaynerMedia
and then like a month into
him thinking about his future
he's like I want to run
this and I'm like, let's go.
I love this, you have the Jets.
I'm very excited right now.
I'm in the best mood.
This is amazing.
You know, some people see
the cross or a Jewish star,
that's my religion.
I see this and I'm like excited.
That's what's up.
(laughing)
You know, I tore both my
meniscuses within that four year
period prior but it was
really interesting to learn
about that and the abductor
and just my biggest thing
that I've learned in the
last four years that I love
that I never hear people
talk about is tissue quality.
That's been huge for me.
Just like fascia.
These kids are probably
too athletic and they don't
deal with that shit but
old folks like me...
- [Man] Oh, that's the
thing is like I feel like
that's our job is to prevent
the soft tissue injuries.
If you can do that, you're golden.
In my mind like as a strength coach.
There's all these facets
to it and whatever
and I'm trying to change the game.
- Do you watch the film of them lift?
- [Man] Lift, yes.
We film as much as we can.
- Yeah.
That's the game.
- I believe in that shit.
- Yeah.
- I know Dick and I can
see little like even as
I've started getting a
little more flexible,
a little stronger.
Even like my buff friends, I'm
like how about flexibility?
So like I'll play that game
before they blow me out
in like lifting.
All these guys, like
normal folk, you know,
they have no fucking flexibility.
- [Man] That's like longevity.
- That's what I'm thinking, that's right.
- That's like if you're
flexible, you're good.
- In my world, all these
people think they're fucking
superstars when they run
departments for my company.
Until you're the fucking
CEO, the best part of being
somebody placed 25% of your
snaps or kill on special team
is you get to blame the
person ahead of you.
But when you're on the fucking lights.
That's what I love about sports
that I hate about business.
You can't count as easily.
Like you miss a tackle,
you're watching on Sunday,
Monday, whatever the
fuck you guys do film.
It's like, you missed that tackle.
It's so much accountability,
I hate our fucking company.
They can fucking hide everywhere.
They're in the meeting, why
are they in that meeting?
Can't see that.
I need to start filming meetings.
That would be fucking amazing.
If we started filming every
meeting in the building
and I can watch them, I can
be like yo, what the fuck
were you doing in that meeting?
About to give a talk to
the 'Bama football team,
national champs.
I'm a national champ.
Feels natural.
Even though I'm rich and I
made it and I did a good thing,
I like the process, I like the game,
I like being an entrepreneur.
Some of you guys in
here love, love playing.
Others are just cool with it.
It's your way out.
There's a million different variables.
Some people can't breathe without it.
I can't breathe without the game.
I can't breathe without being busy.
I can't breathe without
working 15 hours a day.
every minute being scheduled.
I woke up at 4:30 this
morning, went to Chicago,
met with Craft, got on a
plane here, now with you guys,
gonna drive to Atlanta tonight
because I got a meeting.
Like just in it.
Just in it.
I'm going to be in the
studio with Sonny Digital
until three A.M. tonight
and then at seven A.M.
be at a meeting so just in
it because I love my process,
I love my game.
That is what I've been
spending more time on
in the last three, four, five years.
That's the thing I think
I can bring value here
because you're all gonna
have different paths.
The thing that I become fascinated with
is where's your mind at, right?
To me, for example, I'm
going to throw you something
I've been thinking about
on the flight down here.
To me, the craziest thing
is that for most of you,
your talent is your vulnerability.
That like plays with my head.
The fact that your talent is
actually your vulnerability
because it's been so given to you
you don't know any different.
I know you're talented
because I can context
how fast you can run, what
you can do, what you can live,
how you can play, but your
talent is the vulnerability.
To me, how you get over
there and understand that.
For me, what's super interesting
is on some straight facts
for 80% of you, this is
the apex of your life.
You're a 'Bama ball player.
Most of you are not going
to be in the League.
Most of you are definitely
not going to be in the League
for more than three years.
Just math.
What do you do with all the
leverage you have right now?
To me, I think a lot about
when I talk to some of the kids
on DM and shit like that, I
think about are they really
leveraging their moment?
Do they understand while
they're the big dog
on campus right now that
the kid sitting next to them
in chemistry class in six
years is going to have
all of the leverage and they're not
and they're too cool to
say hello to somebody
and that leverage can change
the course of their life?
So for me, when I walk here,
I got a few minutes with coach
and he was like what are
you going to talk about?
The only thing that kept
running through my mouth
is like who in here, which
fringe special teams player,
which third string line backer,
like who is going to hear
what I have to say?
Which is this is the greatest
era to ever be alive.
Coach, I, others, we didn't grow up
with this internet thing.
The access and ability you
have to do whatever you want
is extraordinary.
It's almost uncomfortable.
It's amazing.
A couple guys in my team
are here, we walk by
and a big sign in the
hall said no excuses.
I just got so happy.
To me, it's just 100% accountability.
To me, this is all about happiness.
Like life, happiness.
To me, this is just the easiest
way I know how to be happy
is to blame myself for everything.
All of it.
There's tactics, you know,
I was talking to coach
about ET, ET's my guy,
coming through here.
He's like ET challenged
them to be off social media
for 30 days.
I was like, why the fuck would he do that?
Because that's a tactic.
That's short term, right?
That's cool.
You check that box but the
reality is it's more about
controlling what's happening.
To me, technology is
the great ammo for you.
I hate when people talk about millennials
and this and that.
For me, this is it.
You guys are the best at this.
You understand it the best.
You are the best version.
It's always the evolution.
But do you know how to
make it work for you?
That's a mindset game.
Thank you so much for having me.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Any time, any time.
- I love watching your stuff too.
- Thank you, my guy.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you, man.
- My pleasure, guy.
Good luck this season;
take care of yourself.
My guy, take care of yourself.
- Appreciate it.
- Thank you, my man.
Thank you so much.
- Appreciate it.
- Thanks, man.
Thanks for coming through.
Thank you for your question today.
You got it?
You understand?
Leverage it.
I see you seeing it.
- I'll see you outside.
- I appreciate it, my guy.
Thank you for listening.
Yeah, take care of yourself.
- Appreciate it.
- Thank you so much.
- I'm all fired up.
- Thank you, man.
Thank you so much, man; good luck to you.
- Appreciate the insight.
- Thank you, my guy.
Good luck, okay?
- Appreciate it.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, my dude.
Take care.
- Appreciate it, man.
- Thank you, man; appreciate it.
Thank you.
- Hey, thanks for coming.
- I hope you enjoyed it.
- Thank you; appreciate it.
Thank you.
- Good luck this season.
- Thank you.
- Appreciate you, man.
- Thank you, man.
Stay well; take care of yourself.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much, my man.
Thank you, bro.
- I follow you on social media.
I'll hit you up later.
- Thank you, man.
Hit me up.
Thank you, man, thank you.
- [Man] Did you start a
shoe company, by the way?
- I did a K-Swiss deal.
You know what, and
listen, I got more money
on a shoe deal from K-Swiss
than 99% of the players
in the NFL.
You understand?
- Shoes do it.
- I know shoes do it.
That's why I did it.
Thank you, man; thank
you for coming through.
All right, my man.
- Appreciate it.
- I hope you enjoyed it.
- All right, dude, thank you so much.
- Of course, my guy.
- I'm gonna make sure I reach out to you.
- Hit me, hit me.
- I appreciate that.
- Thank you, man.
I hope you enjoyed it; take care.
- You're a great man.
- Thank you.
- My name is Richie, I
follow you on social media.
I asked a question about the social media.
- Hit me up, say what's up.
I'll help you any time.
- Appreciate the information.
- Yeah, man.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Yeah, man, take care.
- You have so much good info.
- Thank you, man.
Thank you.
All right, my guy; appreciate it.
Thank you, man; thank you for your time.
Thank you for your time, my
man; thank you for listening.
- Appreciate it.
- All right, my guy.
Thank you for listening.
- Thank you.
- My pleasure, man.
Thank you for listening.
- Appreciate it, man.
- Hope you enjoyed it.
Take care.
- Hey, I saw you
on KFC radio.
- Yes.
- That shit was hilarious.
- Those fucking guys are amazing.
You enjoyed it?
- Yeah.
- That's what's up, man; thank you.
- Appreciate it, dog.
- Thanks, man.
- Thanks so much.
- Nice fucking hair.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, man.
Thanks for your time.
- I appreciate it, man.
- Thank you, man; take care.
- I'm gonna check up with
you about the Amazon thing.
- Yeah, man, hit me up.
Let me know how I can help.
I appreciate it, man;
thanks for listening.
- I appreciate it.
What's up with Bitcoin?
Do you think it's done with?
- I don't think it's done with but crypto
is fucking gangster right now.
There's so many jokers in it, you know?
It's just unstable like
back to the question
like Amazon, you can go to
sleep but everybody wants
to go after Bitcoin because
they think they're going to be
a billionaire in a week.
It's the same shit always.
- I gotcha.
- You know?
- Awesome to see you, man.
- Thank you, man.
- Can I get your contact information?
- 100%, 100%.
Hit me up, hit me up.
- I appreciate it.
- Thank you, man.
Thanks for listening.
- I'm definitely gonna DM you.
- Please, man.
Yeah, anything I can help you with.
What's up, my guy?
Hit me up.
- I appreciate it.
- Thank you, man, stay well.
All right, fella; thank you so much.
- Hey, appreciate it.
- Thank you.
I love that, I saw
everybody looking at you.
- You got a Twitter the same as Instagram?
- Yeah I GaryVee.
Yeah, hit me up.
- I'm gonna shoot you a DM on Instagram.
- Please, please.
- Appreciate you
very much.
- Yeah, man.
I'm glad you enjoyed it; stay well.
(mumbling)
Man, but you know what?
Right now, everyone is on a high.
I want to know about
next Thursday, you know?
Next Thursday.
The best flip is go on
Craigslist, people giving stuff
away for free?
Just go pick it up and
throw it in your truck,
put it on Facebook and sell it for $40.
You know like it means something.
I have all my fancy friends being like oh,
I'm like you're a fucking dick.
You make 400,000 a year.
Of course 800 bucks a month
doesn't mean anything to you.
I'm like, I came from nothing.
I know what 800 bucks a month...
You know what 800 bucks a month extra
for you guys are right now?
Fucking do something with it.
The fact that that's
like you guys are tough.
I'm not even worried about you.
You're busy.
You're student athletes.
You're not even on my radar.
I'm talking about people
that literally come home
at five o'clock, sit on
their couch, play three hours
of fucking 2K, watch
eight hours of Netflix,
and then tweet that the world's
fucked and everything sucks.
I'm like, motherfucker,
do something, you know?
For you, I don't like to
say much because like damn,
between how hard they
fucking got you working
and you gotta do class
and whatever the fuck else
is going on in your life.
I'm like, shit, you
guys are the last people
that have time.
You still have time, you know what I mean?
Your biggest problem is the money day
is Saturday morning.
Thank you, my guys.
You know, Saturday morning
is like garage sale,
flea market, you know?
The big game in that world
is you go to a garage sale,
somebody doesn't know
what the fuck is going on,
you buy something for $20 and it's a bunch
of video games and you
make $800 in one shot.
All right, fellas, take care.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you so much for the invite.
- What they got out of that, you're right.
- Yeah, man, that makes
me happy, you know?
- [Gary] Let us know if you wanna come.
- I will let you know.
- Appreciate it.
- [Gary] Thank you, guys; take care.
Thank you so much.
Tell coach thanks for the hospitality.
- Hey, appreciate you all, man.
- Love you, man.
- Thank you all, too.
- We'll touch.
Hello.
- How you doing?
- Very good.
- You Gary?
- Yes, how are you?
- I'm good, I'm Kim.
- Kim, thank you so much.
Heading to the studio.
- This guy right here.
- What up, what up?
Nice to meet you, my guy.
How are you?
- Good, good.
I literally watch all your shit.
- That's what's up.
- For real.
- Thank you so much.
- It's good stuff, man.
That shit gets me through my day, bro.
- How are you?
- I'm good.
- Good, man; I appreciate that.
Let's go on inside.
Let's go.
- One o'clock.
- In the afternoon?
- Yeah, thank you.
You've just been everywhere today, huh?
- Yeah, man.
- What's up, fella?
- What up, my man?
- We all right.
- How are you?
What's up, fellas?
- What up?
- How you doing, man?
- How are you, man?
How you been?
- Blessed, man, working.
- It's good to see you.
That's what's up.
How are you, my guy?
It's good to see you.
What's up, my man?
How are you?
- It's been like two years in the making.
- [Man] Yeah, man.
Really like three.
- How are you?
Real pleasure.
- Been killing that gear.
- Trying, man; trying, man.
- Y'all pulled that shit right now.
- It's great, man.
This is a nice little studio.
I haven't been through
Atlanta in a minute.
I was here for like one
talk but we were trying
to fucking get here for like a year.
- That is because that
last time I seen you
was in New York and you was telling me.
I think the only day you
came was for like a Cavs game
or something like that.
- I didn't even make that.
I didn't even make that.
Project drop, everyone's happy?
- Oh yeah.
(laughing)
- How long would that
be, like eight years?
- Seven, eight years.
The loud noises get you cozy.
Oh my god.
What's up, baby?
Congratulations, man.
- Meet the man in the middle.
(laughing)
You know what I'm saying?
(mumbling)
- How you doing, man?
Congrats, man.
- Thank you, man.
(mumbling)
- Yo, can we listen to
Middle Fingers again?
- Yes, we can.
- Let's put it on.
- Let's play Middle Fingers on
the big speaker god damn it.
What you think about it?
The fuck?
(mumbling)
♪ That's my partner, they 100 ♪
♪ Fuckin' niggas baby mamas ♪
♪ I'm riding around on my skateboard ♪
♪ Nah, I'm not doing no surfboard ♪
♪ Nigga, like what is you hating for? ♪
♪ Nigga young nigga be hating boy ♪
- Mike, the number one
thing that has to happen
with this project, it's why
I was just making content
for him, like tomorrow morning
like starting right now
you gotta go hard.
People have to fucking post
that post of the album cover.
- It's all over my timeline right now.
- You know how it is, right?
Like when a new project drops now.
Everybody needs to give you
a cosign with the fucking
photo on it.
It's as simple as that.
It's not complicated.
You know what I mean?
Like every producer.
Everybody you've fucked with,
everybody who fucks with you.
This is not the time
to be bashful or proud.
It's like yo, put this up.
You know what I mean?
Because when people wake
up tomorrow or this weekend
and go through their
timeline and they just see
like 15 people they fuck
with with that cover?
I watch this shit.
Like if you look at Lil Baby's project?
That's how shit happens.
Culture lives on Instagram.
You win on Instagram,
you win in real life.
You lose on Instagram,
you lose in real life.
To me, that's why I just
like put it in the story
and tagged everything and pushing it.
That's where the attention is.
You know, and like you gotta win on like
Madison Avenue, you gotta
win on Silicon Valley,
you gotta win Hollywood, you
gotta win in the streets.
You gotta like just
win in every direction.
The number one thing, Mike,
I think is as many people
as possible in the next seven to nine days
just throwing up the photo of the project.
It's as simple as that.
You know what's crazy?
It's just super simple too.
It's so basic.
It's like when we grew
up, it's like fliers.
It's literally that basic.
It's just that basic.
It's about like just not giving a fuck
and being like yo, this matters to us.
This is an important project.
To me, this is how I think about shit.
This is how I think about you guys.
Just give value, give value,
give value, give value.
Like you give value to
everybody and then once a year
when you need something, you just ask.
If people don't come
through, you'll get upset.
You're like yo, that's just the way it is.
Who knows what the fuck is
going on with their life.
But like you get seven out
of ten people that you ask
to post it?
Fucking matters.
The way it is.
Think about it, what?
Outside of Rap Caviar,
outside of like big playlists,
like what?
What else?
What are we talking about now in music?
Right?
You either get cosigned
on some playlists, right?
Which gets you a bunch of fucking exposure
that nobody knew, or you
win on fucking Instagram.
It's like, literally I think of Instagram,
explore and just Instagram
feed and Rap Caviar,
the way I thought about
music coming out with MTV
and BET and that's it.
Thank you very much.
(mumbling)
What up, vlog?
It's, you know, just a
normal 2:34 in the morning
here in Atlanta outside
the studio, you know.
Just a normal day.
- Gary, what's up, brother?
- What's up, my guy?
It's a real pleasure.
- Thank you.
- Real pleasure, man.
I've been looking forward to it.
- Sunny, sunny place right here.
- Sunny, sunny delight.
- It's still in the works right now.
- What's up, my guy?
- How are you?
- Real good, you?
- Fucking good to see you, man.
- Good to see you.
- What's up, man?
- What's up, bro?
- [Riley] Hi, how are you?
My name is Riley.
- Hi, I'm Gary.
- Nice to meet you.
Give me the love, give me love.
- How are you doing, I'm Riley.
- I'm Mike.
- Nice to meet you.
- Crazy.
- Yo, we still talking
about Travis Porter.
- Still.
I tweeted about it.
You saw it?
- I was the one that tweeted you back.
I was like awe, since Gary V. said it...
- We might have to do it.
- Josh.
- This is my guy, Josh,
right here.
(laughing)
- [Gary] I love it.
I like the wine.
Yeah, man, I still think
about that all the time.
Literally just as you saw.
- I seen it the other day.
How many of y'all miss Travis Porter?
- Oh, so much.
So much.
(funky upbeat music)
- This is dope.
- Real good.
You know what it was?
Like I just feel like the
same thing with anything
like people just know.
People know when you're slapping your name
on something just trying to make money
or if you're like into it.
For me, K-Swiss was perfect because I'm 42
so when I was a kid, K-Swiss was real.
If you googled K-Swiss 1980's right now,
the first three Google images
are Dr. Dre wearing them,
Ice-T wearing them and
Mike Tyson wearing them.
Yeah because some people are
like corny, corny, corny,
you know, like when I first announced it.
I saved all the photos and
I went right into Twitter
and I was like reply, reply, reply.
Everyone was like oh, shit, you know?
They're like wait a minute.
I said to one kid I was
like yo, I remember sneakers
before Jordan had one.
He was like what?
(mumbling)
I felt people were just
barefoot back then.
Converse has been coming
out with some cool shit.
Some of the new stuff they've been doing?
The off-white stuff is incredible.
Those collabs.
(mumbling)
They all look cool.
- [Riley] He got women's boots.
- Oh, yeah.
- Off-white up the side.
(mumbling)
- I'm so happy for him.
He broke new ground.
He did real work.
Do you know how many little
kids sit looking at him now
are dreaming and think they can?
That shit matters.
That shit fucking matters.
People don't get it.
People do not understand.
Like when I was growing
up, I was born in Russia
and we came to America
and being Jewish in Russia
after the war was real not good.
So for my grandma, like you
know, she lived in the woods
for two years.
(mumbling)
I don't remember, I was three when I came.
But my grandma, she left
when she was 40 something
and she grew up during the war as a kid
and like after the war, World War II,
everybody blamed Jews for everything.
You know, millions of people died.
Millions.
You know like when six people die...
It was fucked up.
Anyway, as a kid growing up,
if anybody that was Jewish
or had a Jewish name
showed up on TV, my grandma
would go crazy.
We could be just eating
dinner and like somebody
like Howard Greenberg would be
like talking about some shit
and she would say in Russian "Jew, Jew."
It used to annoy me and I
thought it was whatever.
As I got older, older,
older, I'm like man,
she came from such a place
where like nobody broke out.
Everybody was suppressed and went to jail.
So like, you know?
Literally it was crazy
when the Virgil news
was announced, it was crazy.
The first thing I thought
about was my grandma.
I'm like, how many of
my grandma, little kids,
who want to be fashion
designers that are in the hood
can't even begin to think
about I'm going to be
the lead designer for Gucci, right?
Now just sit there and
they're like oh, maybe I can.
Fucking powerful.
(mumbling)
My guy.
- I appreciate you
coming through.
- Yeah, man.
I wanted to show you real love.
Let's take this photo.
I got this, boy, don't worry.
I don't think I've posted a
four A.M. Instagram post ever.
Right now.
(mumbling)
I mean this is absurdity.
I'm gonna pull up my Instagram story
because I'm gonna give it to you, D-Rock,
to start this day with.
Save.
We're 23 hours in and this
was already in the car.
This is a 24 hour fucking...
This is a banger of a day.
Get your AirPlay open, D-Rock.
Vlog, I love you.
We did it today.
We really did it today.
The train knows.
♪ I give thanks to the most high ♪
♪ Fuck going platinum ♪
♪ I pray to be multi ♪
♪ One more time ♪
♪ I give thanks to the most high ♪
♪ Fuck going platinum ♪
♪ I pray to be multi ♪
♪ John Bugus ♪
("Give Thanks" by Bugus)